all right my talk at the table uh may be
filed under
tell me something i don't know however
i'm gonna tell you anyway because it'll
make you feel a little bit better it's
not only you a new study suggests that
many americans have experienced
significant weight change
during the pandemic so researchers at uc
san francisco
tracked data from smart scales and they
found that during the
shelter in place orders in march and
april
of last year americans gained
approximately one and a half pounds a
month one and a half pounds a month ouch
so if you kept up that pace throughout
the year that would be about
20 pounds in the course of a year and
in this same month the american
psychology psychological association
had a survey on stress that found 42
percent of americans said they gained
weight the average
29 pounds even more than that yeah
i believe that we are a nation of fatty
fat fats even without the coconut
but i got on the scale the other day
with my eyes closed and then i couldn't
even open my eyes i got off without even
looking
because i already know it i love you i
have a mirror that counts as a trip to
the scale
i went to the doctor i went to the
doctor they read out the number out loud
i i
it was i was approaching a number i had
never approached before and uh
it turns out i'm not getting taller just
wider we can all do something about it